let's get more reaction now to the
warnings by police in Northern Ireland
that dissident Republicans could be
planning a terror attack for the
anniversary of a good Friday agreement
well Lord dannett former Chief of the
general staff joins me now great to have
you with us Lord Janet thank you very
much indeed for joining us I know that
you served in Northern Ireland when you
were in the military in the 1970s your
take on the current security situation
there
well I think one has to accept that as
successful as the Good Friday agreement
has been and has produced 25 years of
much more peaceful environment in
Northern Ireland a number of the
underlying issues are still there
um the Republican Community would like
to see many of them most of them perhaps
would like to see Northern Ireland part
of the overall Island one state and the
unionists want to remain part of the
United Kingdom so there's underlying
issues are there I think as far as the
threat as it stands at the present
moment is concerned from decision
Republicans from the moment that the
provisional Ira declared a ceasefire and
the green and the Good Friday agreement
was signed there was always going to be
a dissident element that would want to
continue the fight uh in a violent way
and that's what we're seeing and I think
perfectly sensibly as we're coming up to
the 25th anniversary of the signing of
the Good Friday agreement and high
profile people like President Joe Biden
coming to Northern Ireland to visit that
quite essentially the security level has
been raised and that there are concerns
that there might be sporadic violence
but um if there is it'll be nothing like
on the same scale that we've seen in the
past and most certainly not with the
popular support that the provisional Ira
I previously enjoyed
of course we have we have seen
um you know more activity from distant
Republicans of late of course that that
senior police officer who was attacked
and left with life-changing injuries
last month uh do you think they are
becoming more active in Northern Ireland
well there's been a steady trickle of
violent activities over the last 25
years
um yes you're quite right to point to
that Shameless attack on uh off duty
policeman uh last month but sadly there
have been periodic incidents like that
and I think it's quite reasonable that
the security services are being wise in
pointing to the possibility of these
sort of attacks being mounted again at
this critical 25-year anniversary and
particularly when the world's media
courtesy of Joe Biden and Tony Blair and
others are looking at Northern Ireland
um
the nature of these things is that
attacks will be carried out
and as horrific as they might or might
not be if they're done in the glare of
publicity their effect is maximized and
of course that's what the concern is
next week and that's why I think quite
sensibly uh security levels have been
raised
what's your take on on the future of
Northern Ireland do younger Generations
care as much about religious and
political divides
well I think the younger generation if
we're talking about people born in the
last 25 years have enjoyed the much more
peaceful society that the Good Friday
agreement gave them
um I was looking at something and quite
recently
um which is an East-West bus service if
you like across Belfast well that would
never have happened 25 30 years ago if
you lived in East Belfast you wouldn't
have gone to West Belfast and and vice
versa City Center was surrounded by a
ring of Steel well all that has changed
all that has gone on that's that's much
for the better but there is still
progress to be made and as I said a few
minutes ago the underlying issues are
still there and will probably always
remain there and it's exacerbated by the
fact that the Democratic process has now
put Sinn Fein as the largest political
party of Stormwind if indeed a storm
what was ever to sit again and the dup
uh don't like the fact that they're in a
minority so these tensions are still
there and it's it's most unfortunate
that the Stormwind devot assembly uh is
not sitting it has not sat for some time
that is not good for the governance of
Northern Ireland and frankly
um
it's not for me to say so but I'm
disappointed the Democratic unionist
party under Jeffrey Donaldson has not
accepted the protocol that by Rishi
sunak negotiated and allowed Northern
Ireland to move forward and frankly also
to allow the rest of the United Kingdom
to move forward as well with a better
relationship within with the European
Union
that's an interesting point you you make
there about the political vacuum we're
seeing at the moment in Northern Ireland
but you saw Northern Ireland during some
of the most tense years Lord dannett and
I'm always struck uh when I go to
Belfast by the peace Wars that still
exist that essentially uh separate
Catholic and Protestant areas of the
city are they still needed 25 years on
from The Good Friday agreement
well the fact that they're still there
rather indicates that they are still
needed but um as I was just saying a
moment or two ago
um things have improved considerably
things have changed and I would like to
think that over the next 5 10 15 maybe
25 years that the visible symbols of
division uh will disappear and that
there will be a greater coming together
and integration of people
um we see that throughout the rest of
the United Kingdom it would be really
good to see that in Northern Ireland but
if one can't get away from the fact that
on the island of Ireland there does
remain this double minority situation
that if you take the whole of Ireland
the Protestants are in the minority if
you take Northern Ireland previously the
Catholics the Republicans were in the
minority but that has changed and
they're pretty much in balance as The
Ballot Box has shown so
um the underlying issues are there but
the demographics are changing them and
one just hopes and prays that peace will
remain in Northern Ireland and they'll
be continuing coming together of
communities so that people can live in a
peaceful and prosperous way it's not too
much to ask it's a reasonable hope to
Aspire to and when I look back when I
was first in Belfast in August 1971 the
violence was so intense we really
couldn't see how things could ever get
better well 50 years on they have 25
years on for the Good Friday agreement
they have and that is good and that
vindicates
the politics of Hope if you like and
frankly I for one do remain rather
supporter of hope it might sound a bit
naive and immature but actually in life
without hope there's often not a lot and
we hope for better times in Northern and
people have got them there now
lordana we really appreciate your
thoughts today thank you for joining us
and have a happy Easter same to you
thanks